what made you one of being your wife
were you guys just total just [ __ ]
out of the gate or like what was the
whole deal there yeah no my wife my wife
was your wife's a beautiful lady to
manage spend time Rose are very sweet
she's great she's great
I started she didn't get a real short
haircut did she know okay good and
that's something that does in cuz a lot
of couples start to look the same as
they get older and if they're still
[ __ ] the night you got a shot that to
me is there something else is going on
no it's like they're just trying to make
one person as hard as they can I had sex
with a girl a day that's grown College
you cut her all her hair got a pixie
haircut and we're having sex
and as we're [ __ ] I'm drunk right
eyes are [ __ ] I went he's like
[ __ ] a dude and I was like woah woah
oh yeah I was like well that's a buck um
I met LeAnn and we dated for a little
bit I didn't put a label on it and then
she dumped me hmm and then when she
dumped me I fought to get her back I
made her a mix tape I did everything
what else do you do everything honestly
Oh try I was crying
yeah driving down like you poppy flowers
no I'm [ __ ] crying okay I made salt
water with my eyes I went to an AAA
meeting I did everything I was in a
meeting dude I gotta say meeting in
there like and I'm with this guy I guess
I shouldn't say his name but uh he's
like he's like you should stand up and
talk and I was like I was just lost man
I wanted this chick back wow what did
you say this is great cuz I go to a
meeting so what do you say if you so
they go um I love this was like alright
I go I don't know if I feel comfortable
talking I don't really made any
decisions about what I'm doing in my
life I'm just trying to like get this
chick back and see if I have a problem
because the reason we broke up is I
gotten drunk at a dinner party and I
just argued with her friend and I
wouldn't let it go and so I could see
that and so uh he goes yeah I just talk
I'm like okay I'm gonna talk and part of
me is a comic I'm like yeah I gotta get
a pen say I'm a little little stage time
is bad guy in front of me little stage I
love it there I go to get I gotta stand
up right and then the guy in front of me
stands up he goes do you mind if I go
and I was like oh sorry yeah go ahead
he stands up and he goes hi my name's
Dave or whatever yeah I'm an alcoholic
and everyone's like hi Dave
he's like it's been a rough day
who this morning my landlord came over
and I sucked his dick and then I lit his
car on fire oh my god and I was like I
can't follow that yeah let somebody else
go I can't go right after that I'm gonna
[ __ ] eat a bullet up guy you're like
this is the crystally of a meeting so I
didn't say anything left and I was like
I was like I don't know if that's for me
and then and then like the next day I
wanted a jog down outpost I came running
down outpost on to Franklin I live right
over by Hollywood Island and I and I was
I was like I don't know what for me you
were out here when you met your lady oh
yeah yeah yeah and I was like I don't
know what's wrong with me I feel like I
I don't I was like I really don't feel
like I have a drinking problem I really
don't feel like my going need to stay
sober for a while get my head straight
if I'm gonna be single I need to figure
out what I'm doing with my life and I
had this a moment that I spoke to God
gods and I think God said if you want
her back he's just got a promise that
she's the one and you won't [ __ ] it up I
swear to God I spoke to God no idea and
I was like I go I'll never [ __ ] this up
just give her to me
and I will never [ __ ] it up I'll marry
her and this will be my chick this is
the one for me he's like I remember him
saying in my head to me mmm
remember who just said I got home and
she was in my bedroom on my bed and she
was in a sundress and she goes I think
we need to figure out how to what was
she doing in there she had just gone to
church she'd gone to a church down in
Compton cuz she's Baptist and you come
on up here and she'd gone to a church in
Compton and and in church someone had
said to her in her head you need to get
this guy this guy's a good guy he needs
a second chance
Wow and so then we just we hung out we
had a great time didn't party for like
six months it didn't drink for like six
months and then one day we're in Italy
it's New Years Eve and it's snowing on
Venice it just starts snowing I'd [ __ ]
you there that sounds beautiful and I
said I said to her I said I gotta be
honest with you this is what I want a
drink is like it's snowing we're in same
you drank for six months six months I
didn't drink and I didn't have a like
that's other problems I don't have a
problem quitting drinking like I almost
have a problem starting up again right
it's so like I go I don't I just feel
like gosh I want a drink and she goes
honey I don't think you've a drinking
problem have a drink well we had a cup
we had a but we split a bottle of wine
went out in the snow in st. marks it was
an
see it was [ __ ] empty was like the
day after New Year's Eve town is shut
down and it was [ __ ] gorgeous st.
Mark's st. Mark's is a big square in
Venice it's like just huge and it was
just starting to snow it was like
perfect snow everywhere I was [ __ ]
great and so yeah I've been with her
ever since but then she got nervous cuz
she's like okay I got to introduce you
to my family first thing she said was my
dad my dad lives in a convenience store
okay
and I was like a CES they call him I go
okay and she's like I just want you to
know like you know like my family's from
very humble means yeah I was like
alright sure enough is called Kemp's
corner and it was in Bowden Georgia and
we pulled up about Owen bowd oin no bowd
and Wow and walk into a convenience
store with all your luggage right like
how [ __ ] weird you walk into like a
convenience store with all your luggage
and then walk into the back and put it
in the back and we hung out there went
out to eat came back and the he closes
of a convenience store and we're
sleeping in the freezer right
pitch-black no windows ice cold a love
it's like a cave yeah and the Millman
and like right before bed he's like did
you guys want anything like a snack
before bed no it's like yeah you just
walk into a convenience store I got like
a [ __ ] 40
I got a Snickers bar I got some Reese's
peanut butter cups I was like this is
[ __ ] awesome we're just murdering
food I was like I think I love you I
think I need to marry you I'm gonna get
you pregnant first your redneck you
understand yeah yeah man that's a seaman
first it's dude you got to see if that
[ __ ] chick will play yeah can't take
her to the game not notice you can pitch
yeah and did you guys when do you guys
start making love or you'd already been
making love you know we don't even make
yeah we we had sex probably like five
dates in this back to her Sex in the
City
remember that Sex in the City run we're
all guys thought all girls were [ __ ]
mm-hmm I remember thinking that that
would just even look at on Instagram so
there was a period where women were like
I think it's still there but like Sex in
the City came out and when we're like
yeah I like to [ __ ] and oh I could see
that and now we're in control of our own
[ __ ] and that scared the [ __ ] out of
me cuz I'm only have sex with six people
women why am i sane people what when
it's [ __ ] adult women to don't women
or all the women you ever had sex with
over the age of 18 yeah
yeah even my first one when I was 17 was
[ __ ] yeah do play baby she was a senior
I was lay up dude yeah
JV dude getting up in the bigs huh yeah
and I dated a chick younger than me when
I was 18 and I never [ __ ] her because
I this is gonna sound so creepy that I
would have this wherewithal but even
then I just didn't think it was right so
I was like she's younger than me she was
like a junior I was a senior I was 18
probably 16 set maybe 17 and I was like
I'm going to college and I don't think
that's right to do to someone is take
their virginity and just [ __ ]
imbalance yeah yeah that's not cool and
I never had sex with her Wow yep
shoutout to Jen Bethea hey what if she
showed up now do you think your wife
would give you a pass she's married to a
guy that I [ __ ] really respect but no
she's smoking and what if some day gem
buffet is gorgeous to this day what if
something happened to that guy if
something happened to both our wives and
me and her ended up like say we're all
on a cruise right and and it's like the
end of infinity Wars like half the
people just die yeah that's me and Jen I
still would no no no she's complicated
I love he's like one of my close friends
but but what she's just a complicated
person she is yeah she can [ __ ] work
she can work you into a spiral oh she's
great though yeah but yeah I don't I
mean I don't know I know her too well is
like I've known her for almost like a
little sister well my whole life now
because after that you know I went to
Florida State then she moved out to LA
she was a stylist for a while Lily yeah
she's great and you saw her getting you
got time you were dating your lady here
with your lady
oh you have known her date when I was
dating my chick I've known her she's
dated a couple of my friends I love her
but like I could man she's she's way too
much have you and your wife ever thought
about like doing swinging or anything
like that not even remotely Lily that's
so not LeAnn LeAnn Oh Liam barely wants
to [ __ ] me yeah let alone other people
huh yeah that's true I think she's got a
crush on you though really yeah she's a
lot she loves you man she's a lady
you know what's crazy as my sister can't
even read but what does it have to do
with us right now hope you enjoyed that
video and you can watch another and you
can watch this one you can watch this
one different options different choices
some guy just brings you one option not
this guy
two options watch one this one or this
one